what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i have a
special guest on the channel he's been
on before this is ken
um he is going to be filling in the
place of the whitest guy on earth
so today we are going to be reacting to
kevin samuels before i start do not
forget to subscribe to the channel and
bring that notification bell the way
you're going to be notified of my daily
videos while you're at it go follow my
instagram it's just probably things but
instead of an s at the end it's a z
so we are going to be reacting to the
your average at best video
you've never seen this before this video
okay so it's gonna be for the first time
[Music]
those were hers
hey can you hear me yeah are you a phd
ah no i'm a phd
how many dogs you got
i won
really
i'm sorry what kind of dog is it he's a
cane corso
he's a what
a cane corso
what is that in english
um it's a larger dog and their breed is
meant for guarding and protecting
they're very protective of their home
and their families so what's your
disagreement
um honestly i don't have a disagreement
i just came here because i honestly want
some advice from you
it says disagreement day i know this is
my first time catching on live normally
i'm asleep
and um you have a job
i do i own a business okay so i do too
and i still have a question but i have a
business disrespected by wednesdays or
whatever he's doing say that again so
he's just she and he's like i do too and
you're disrespecting my business because
you're calling me on the wrong day
well you can book a session on this
website okay yeah so the fact that she
was already like i'm sleep not
i'm asleep like i want to know what her
business is i hope he i hope he goes at
her and like
he must know what a king corso is come
on i don't you don't dude they're huge
kind of ugly but they're like they're
like attack dogs
like they are like banned from like most
apartment buildings like because they're
an aggressive breed which
oh they're kind of cute they're kind of
cute yeah but i like the snouts though
but like imagine but they're huge too
i've always wanted a bull mastiff i love
i love me they're cute
i really like big [ __ ]
i really just well he doesn't
if you wanted my advice
you could always book a session if you
can't catch us if the show live
i'm definitely i was trying to go online
um earlier
but all you have to do man but see what
kind of business do you own
i own a pet grumman doggy daycare and
okay so
what you're basically trying to do is i
have a disagreement day and you
basically came in and said damn your
topic
i want to ask you what i want to ask you
and that's but you are more than welcome
to go on my website and purchase your
time to talk with me one-on-one
because what you're trying to do is
rather rude but i will go ahead and do
it because i'm going to use this as a
teaching lesson how are you
how old are you i'm 35.
35 years old
35 years old and you're a business owner
uh-huh uh-huh and what's your question
um so uh my issue is well i want to know
what's going to be what she's better
looking than i thought she was going to
be oh really one point would you rank
her one to ten so
i should do eight is beyonce
when um
just meeting a guy do i tell her that
i'm a business owner that's right
my problems are like maybe like a five
she's not ugly okay but like
i'm not going out of my way
okay
when i try to date down and i the
conversation comes up to where i own the
business um the guy is either like hey
can i come join in on you on that
business or can i put some in it
what take that back she's a little beat
like like
it's not for not for me like never i i
thought she was gonna be like really
ugly not gonna lie okay you stand by the
five though no i'm gonna downgrade her
to a four
okay business partner and you feel bad
someone's probably doing it somewhere
what someone's probably doing this to me
so
they will actually i've been rated many
times i'm looking for that and i
honestly oh
hold on hold on hold on hold on i need
to be clear on this subject where are
you where are you at
north carolina
and you're saying when to tell somebody
you own a business
because um i find when i date down
god
to your interest and want to be like a
business partner and i'm i'm learning
that maybe i need a high value name
because that's well first off um
do you know what a high value man is i'm
i mean i guess that someone who's like
has a good job makes a good amount of
money like has
prospects if you will
owns assets or something so they're
they're gonna roast me because every
single time i forget what all five
there's like five requirements one of
them's like he can't be having like they
call it dick discipline so you can't be
having like kids left and right and like
[ __ ] every hoe basically
um
second thing is like he
has to make six figures or more okay um
the other thing is it can't be like
entertainers they don't count so it has
to be in like like actual an actual
business field or actually something
more sustainable something like you
actually control the input as opposed to
like yeah it's dictated by the market
yes yeah um
oh and he has to be helpful to others so
he has to have like a network of like
other high value men okay so like he has
to like know basically other people make
a lot of money and then i forgot the
fourth but so she's saying like as a
four that she like should date a higher
money
well it sounds like a dog care business
in north carolina so like
how low is the
i just like have so many questions
because like she's already started when
you talk she's already starting it out
with like
okay so
i like when do i tell people basically
what do i do like what do you mean like
are you like four dates in with some
rando you meet at a bar before you're
like by the way like are you on food
stamps like
that's like the first [ __ ] question
you ask anyone right it's literally like
i mean i don't agree that should be the
first question but it's literally like
what do you do
right so it's like i have a i own a
business like what do you mean like when
do i bring it up like are you on dating
apps you're on eharmony like do you not
have a [ __ ] profile
i just like i need to know where she
meets the people that she's like
complaining about because she's choosing
them right right so her already like
she's like
i'm dating down right so she already has
like a perception of herself right and
then she's choosing to date
i i don't know what you because if you
look at like if you're five right what's
an average guy make you think
the average salary is
thirty seven thousand dollars is it i
heard it was 45 for men is i i was just
saying average salary oh okay yeah i
think i thought i was 38 from a woman
and 45 i could be wrong i don't know but
regardless so like if she's below
average what does she qualify for
well that gets back to kind of like what
we're talking about yesterday where it's
like if you're below average you make a
lot of money but i doubt like her pet
grooming business is like
raking in the the cheddar like in north
carolina like
yeah what is he gonna do cut the dogs
right because she's it already sounds
like she's like a one-woman shop right
she's like i do a pet grooming yeah and
date doggy daycare so like okay i used
to [ __ ] work for rovers like i could
say i did the same thing i have 45 star
reviews i thought i had more [ __ ] on
yelp than you like
okay i'm gonna keep going
ma'am i really understand uh
what kind of man are you talking about
because owning a business is no
different than having a job in my
opinion i know right
i'm not getting what you're saying when
should you
i'm not understanding why this is an
issue
if you're if you're
what kind of men are you what kind of
men are you dating
um i try to give i try to give guys that
not just
achievement you try to do what
i try to get guys that's not on my level
a chance
why what do you mean on your list
what does that mean
that's making six figures or more
but i don't under okay
you try to give guys who are not on your
level a chance
why and i'm
because i want i honestly want a six
figure guy um is what i'm realized okay
so let me just go ahead and edit it out
for you
you ready
the guys you want aren't asking you out
well i'm i haven't been putting myself
out there honestly
but you put yourself out there enough
for the guys you don't want or believe
you to ask you out
those are like guys i met online
right
so
again
the men you want are not asking you out
see you ladies do this
you go and
deal with men who you feel are beneath
you and then you ask how
to fix them i'm not beneath you i don't
know how to fix a guy that doesn't
that's down there that's not my concern
the better question is why can't you get
a guy on your level
that's the real question it's not
well the first
well first of all i would tell you
what i said in here automatically is a
problem
why you would come onto a show that you
know was a disagreement day
it's selfish
it's like well yes ma'am it's like i
want what i want
i don't i don't say things for no reason
that's why i asked you questions you're
35 years old a business owner that means
you understand what business is and you
know this is a business and i have a and
i have a show title and you said
damn your show title i want to talk to
you
but you could have went to my business
and booked time to talk to me but you
wanted what you wanted how you want it
i'm sorry
no it's but what but she doesn't do that
with dating
she's like
dating she makes all the concessions
yeah i'm just like i love when she was
like i want a six-figure man
i guess i'm just like so
you're dating the people beneath you
she's like but now i want like is she
saying that the people that are beneath
her are six figure people or she's
because like she's also said that
they're broke she's she's contradicted
herself like multiple times well i think
she's saying like guys that make less
than her i think that's what she's
saying but girls don't realize guys
don't care about your money especially
guys that make money no but i i would
not care to date like
i've dated people who have made more
money than me like don't i don't care
yeah i feel like you're confident in
yourself or like your own career like
whatever you don't care well we like
like i always say to girls it's the
equivalent of i think i got this
refreshing fit or something but it's the
equivalent of a shoe collection for a
guy like if a guy has a sneaker
collection i'm like ah cool sure but i
don't care
i don't care at all i just like i just i
honestly wish i could just like get her
stats up on the screen where it was like
age 35
salary x well she said she makes six
figures i don't believe her
okay like straight up because she says
she's like online dating right
and then she's like how do i when do i
tell them that like your online date do
not have like a job listed on your
profile
that's on every dating app like it's on
every dating site that's literally like
yeah so is she just like omitting that
because then she's purposely putting
herself in the lower tier of like
dudes like not that there are dudes with
who make six figures who i sit on these
abs and sit on like e-harmony like i
used to work for the guy who's the vp of
my company who met his wife on
yeah harmony yeah
he harmonies where you go if you're
trying to get married i think that's
what she needs to do it sounds like
she's on tinder well well the problem
with her is that
like she's below average and she's
asking for a guy in the top like 10 of
income earners
but she's in that herself oh she's
insane right right but let's say she
let's say she is do you think that like
guys in the top 10 percent of income
earners care about women's salaries
that's what i'm saying like they don't
like that's what i'm saying so she
thinks that like oh that's a benefit to
a guy and i'm saying no that's like a
shoe collection yeah it's like a nice to
have not a need to yeah cool like a
billionaire will marry a girl that works
at like starbucks if she's pretty enough
and like feminine but also like no
offense to her she's like 35. she's like
yeah she's running out of time yeah her
having a business is almost like
detrimental to like if a guy was like oh
yeah this girl's like awesome or
whatever it's like
but cool we have like two years to like
start having kids like if that yeah
and so she's kind of put herself in a
bad position as well she's not really
eligible
in a lot of ways like
yeah it's like you've built your
career but at what cost
and i'm using this as lesson that's the
problem with too many of you black women
you don't do [ __ ] the right way with
black men
that was improper
and when i even when i told you the
right way you still were like uh well
whatever
so i'mma use this
when was the last time you had a
relationship
um like the end of last year around
december how long did it last
a year
a year uh and was that man uh
did you go to college
did i go to college
yes
no sir
okay and how long have you owned your
own business
nine years
and how and how long have you been
making six figures or more
on the last three
okay why do you need a man making six
figures
um because i'm finding out that the guys
that i think that's not it's not working
out
what does it have to do with money
because i feel like
um
i need a god that i can respect and
admire and i'm a [ __ ] invention and i
want a guy
that i meant
has that drive too and when he doesn't i
find myself you know encouraging like
hey babe you can do this and you can do
that
and then all right so in north carolina
how what percentage of the population
what percentage of men in this country
make six figures or more
i think it's like five percent
i'm not
closer to 10.
so
oh 10
all right so
the question is what do those men who
make that kind of money who all women
tend to want
what do they want
i
feel like they won't arm candy somebody
who can um
have more to bring to the table than
just looks but um
also bring
balance to their life i feel like i can
help them out on um okay slow down i'm
not understanding you said they won't
arm candy then you contradicted yourself
you they want somebody to more than just
looks
yeah arm candy but something about you
know brain with it and
you know more in depth do you want do
you know any men who make six figures or
more
my dad and my uncle
do you
excuse me do you know any men that you
are related to to make six figures or
more
unrelated to
yeah that you are not related to
not on a personal level
so you don't know him
you don't know what they want
but you want him man
i'm going to suggest that you really
don't know
what you want
and saying six figures is just
something that you've got
taken from out there but i'm not hearing
this rooted to anything
but what do you want ultimately do you
want to be married children what
yes i want to be married
do you want any children
yes
how many
um
i have a son you know so
she already
yeah yeah
bring a lot of bring a lot of baggage to
the to the
so if a girl has a kiss do you do you
rule her out completely
yeah yeah you're like no i'm 28. yeah
sorry i don't have my own kids like
how am i supposed to come in and be like
the father figure because like it
doesn't even matter how old that kid is
yes it's like
it tells me one of two things almost
like i wanna know how old the kid is
yeah that's what i wanna know here but
like cool so you
i don't know you had the kid when you
were 18 19.
and now you're literally trying to like
put your life back together after that
it's like
you've built an entire life now
for y'all yeah i would just come in and
[ __ ] it up because unless i have like
very clear like intentions to marry you
off the bat yeah
that's it's honestly a disservice to you
for me well and like then the guy has to
pay for the kid
you know yeah
well i mean she obviously like see
one should those [ __ ] bed sheets are
from amazon because i have the same
[ __ ] one
i know for a fact like those things cost
like 20 bucks that's what i'm saying she
makes six figures she could afford this
session and also she could like afford
to if she's calling in with this like
she got dressed for it right like yeah
but like she's not at all projecting
herself as like
she looks like she's like in college
like this is like something like a
college door she's like sitting on the
edge of her bed like the professionalism
is like on the floor and that's the
other thing that i think with like you
know fans like women who have kids or
whatever it's like
they're not going to have all like the
necessary like maybe decorum yeah that i
would like
be like okay yeah you're like
you've you've made something work for
you yeah and like that's a huge kudos to
you
but where do i fit into that like what
is she looking for she wants to get
married and have kids but like
which then she'd have to put her
business on hold yeah right like is that
something she's willing to do or like
now she's just looking for a man to like
hit a wagon too it's kind of what it
sounds like because she's not gonna be
able to keep doing that yeah so i need
more information about the kid i need to
know where the dad is
would you consider it like it sounds
like because you're saying like you
would need more information about the
kid oh no i meant like for this to help
her for watching this to help her but
not that for you uh i am i'm sorry like
that's just like unnecessary like
the only
way if i was like
early 30s early to mid 30s and i'm
single and i met a woman who like had a
kid and the father died
okay or something yeah otherwise like
it's it just feels like it's gonna be
messy to me like the relationship will
never i'm not ever gonna be like the
father or favor that i want and then
like there's we have kids and then the
kids are potentially presented by the
existing child or by like
well andy shows you're irresponsible too
as a girl because i'm sorry in 2021 you
have no excuse to get knocked up you
have none you can get an iud you can get
birth control you can get condoms and
you plan like there's no push down a
staircase in mexico like there's a lot
of opportunities sorry
[Music]
i'm gonna just keep watching
where's the father there we go he's not
enough in his life
i said where's the father well he's
not like in it like i would like them to
be
no all right so um go ahead and take
this down man
men who make the kind of money you're
talking about have
options and typically i don't want to
deal with women who are have 13 year old
sons who are used to dating men who
this doesn't sound appealing
to the kind of man you're talking about
do you understand what i'm saying
yeah but um i was thinking once i start
booking session with you
that um i can't change men
i know but i can approve myself and i
feel like i have a lot to offer to those
type of me okay but see
you should have stopped right there
i just told you i cannot change men and
you said once i book a session with you
i'm not a miracle worker i'm telling you
what they want
and you're still saying yeah but i want
them they don't want you
but i have been working on myself this
year and um
okay ma'am but okay
35
13 year old son with a sketchy father
why would a man who's in the top 10 of
earners who women across the country
want
want that
um because i have a lot to offer um i
feel like would you want your son
to
if you had a son making that kind of
money
would you want him to bring home a woman
who had a 13 year old son from a sketchy
father or would you prefer him to get a
woman who had no children was younger
and easier to get on his program
depending on his age
this is this
see what i mean see what i mean this
goes so deep for black women
they will
any thoughts so many thoughts
so he's actually being nice it was just
like the funniest part because he's like
top ten percenters but if you actually
broke that down into like the top like
who makes 100k in north carolina right i
feel like that's like we're talking an
impetus so also like knock and hustle
she's probably also looking for a black
guy like so we're talking like tiny tiny
tiny segments of like population so like
let's say there's like 100 people
like that
they have a lot more [ __ ] options
like which is obviously what we talk
about and like what he talks about
well do you know what student's crazy
girls i met a girl who i would say
she's probably a five or a four right
and she makes she makes good money like
over six figures right and so i asked
her she had no kids and she was 30. and
i asked her i said like how much would a
guy have to make to like for you to
consider dating him and when i think
about like like personally i look more
for like work ethic yeah versus like
money you want upwards of mobility in it
right and that's really the workout no
that's what like what work ethic means
they still have like
like growth but i wouldn't care like i
think i was a coach and he was really
passionate about coaching he wanted to
just see how far he could like work hard
and become a coach that's a low-paying
career
but if he was a hard like if he was a
part of it yeah if he's passionate a
hard worker that's yeah so i'm not like
but like i i ask her like just income
you don't know anything else about the
guy like he could be you know um hard
working he could be like anything but
just off income and she said um he would
have to make three hundred thousand i
knew she's gonna be 250 plus i might as
soon as you like you were framing i was
like it's gonna be 250. and i said um
okay um okay would you like consider a
guy to make six figures and she said
like yeah i'm like it wouldn't be my
preference is it okay i said okay what
about what about short guys because i
think girls like if i was a dating
strategist right i would say like like i
think you get a higher income if you go
for like the five five guys
because like girls girls probably didn't
get a lot of chicks in their life so
they've been working real hard yeah no
that's what i'm saying yeah and so i was
like what about a guy shorter than you
he makes that in company shorter than
you dude barely speaks english she's a
software engineer or something makes
400k yeah yeah she said no
i'm like girl
you do not you gotta you and she was
she's not ugly right but
she's like a little bit masculine too
like
slightly overweight
and
like nice enough like i liked her we
hung out but i was just like 300k
and plus what if he's 25. those guys 25
and making 80k that's not bad that's
actually pretty high very good yeah
also it was like 25 million 300k i'd be
very worried yeah about him as long term
but yeah
yeah that's
i feel like we're i lost my train of
thought but we were talking about
something yesterday that was like
kind of exactly like this right and
damn i lost my train of thought
even with her it was the same thing i
told you where like the sixes will be
hooking up with the nines and think
they're like at that level and she was
the same way because we were like
talking about that stuff and she like
she's like yeah like i had some pretty
good conquests and like girl guys will
[ __ ] anything
yeah that's not that's not like a super
don't break i want to be super proud
yeah like it's like oh yeah i [ __ ] an
nba player once it's like yeah you he
literally doesn't remember you like
congrats you might be the third person
that night yeah like
yeah okay so i remembered uh
as a guy who like makes over six videos
right like
almost exactly like what you said we're
like i don't care what they do but like
i said you last night like i care that
they're passionate about or that they're
happy
because if they're unhappy
that's where there's an issue and
they're like
cool they're making like sorry like 150k
or like whatever but they hate it or
like they're like yep i'm going to go
jump and i want to go do this or
whatever like
well then they're not really like i want
somebody who's like stable right like
but happy right right like
i don't know this shit's been killing
you
well and my dad he's the highest like i
don't know anyone that makes more money
than my dad like
and he's always 100 told me to like
chase what you're passionate about
because he's always said like if you're
passionate about it you're going to be
better at it than everyone else because
you're going to be able to put in the
extra hours
yeah and so that's why i've always like
tried to like look at like work ethic
more than like money you know
but i think it's also like a lot of
people will like put their passions on
the side yeah the pursuit of like what
they're told but through traditional
mediums is like the correct path which
is like you go to college then you get
steady job and you're like doing that
and you're like paying dues to society
and like
i just think we have a lot more
information maybe available to us now
that like that's just not like sure
people want to do that they want to do
that but like i put on my [ __ ] tick
tock like how to like like what would
ceos what do like these millionaires
like what would their advice be to like
their younger selves and they all were
like go take some chances yeah do it
when you're young and you're not married
you don't have kids like if you want to
go build something go try it fail
whatever like it's not gonna work like
yeah 90 of those things don't but you
keep doing and you keep adapting and
then you're better and because you're
like oh i tried and i was the ceo and so
i knew how to do like the financing and
the budget and like payroll and
like hiring people firing people like
well even even my dad like how many
parents would i said yeah i'm gonna go
quit my job to be a youtube and
tick-tock
how many parents would be like yeah move
home honey yeah i don't
yeah
your parents are younger than mine i
think
my parents are about 10 years older than
okay so they also just don't really
understand the internet yeah as well at
all there's a pretty big disconnect and
i've like worked for tech companies so
like they understand my dad especially
understands like that side of it like
that i've worked in but i was yeah like
i'm gonna start doing youtube because
i'd have to like almost present it to
him like a business plan yeah and i know
that
but
i
i don't know if i like i knew for like
you know with me and my own content
stuff where it's like well if i just do
it and i put time into it which i do on
the side but then if it just grows into
its own thing then i can i have
something tangible to present so i'm
starting from zero yeah and that's what
i don't think i'd be able to do with my
father but no even driving here was
funny because your house is about seven
times the size of every other house in
the neighborhood
downtown in dirt road
yeah my dad
i always say my dad would be in the high
valley man category if he liked other
people
he doesn't have like he's just kind of
like
got a piece of land and was like yep i'm
good i don't need people he hates the
internet i've tried forever to get him
to come on my channel and give like
young men advice yeah but he always says
no well would can you get him to give
you the advice and like write it down i
do
i do i do that sometimes yeah but what's
his best piece of advice besides
probably what i told you
um i don't know my dad just has always
told me that like
it's like a mentality working hard and
it's a very rare trait um so when i was
a kid like i i've never been good at
school like i've always felt like i was
i was dumb like i'm not saying this to
be mean to myself but i was i was a year
young in school so like when you're a
kid like four or five like that's a big
difference like mentally you know what
i'm saying so i've always felt like i
was behind and my dad he would always
tell me like it doesn't matter you work
hard i'd be like that's so easy for you
to say dad you went to the university of
chicago you're a genius
but like the older i get the more i see
that he was right because like even in
volleyball like i was on the bottom team
at my club i literally never i was a
benchwarmer and then in four years i was
on the first team i was start i was the
like with a bunch of d1 players you know
what i mean like i went i would like
that would always happen in college it
was the same thing like i was benched
ended up like getting all conference my
senior you know what i mean like it was
just
like the same pattern and you said you
get most approved at every job every
everyone not well it's team about not
job they don't really have right
there
that's interesting yeah i saw this thing
where it's like my doctor one most
improved yeah it's like the last thing
you'd want your doctor to win
oh god
that should have been an easy question
no i would not want my son to bring i
want the best for my son that should
have been the appropriate answer
that's why i sat up
that is [ __ ]
you should want the best for your son
of course
but this is
but
and are you thinking
back up
if he brought in
yes i feel like i'm going to accept
but no you're not
that's the problem you all think you're
the exception to the rule but but your
life is proven to you that you're not
my love life is not that good i agree
with you that's my point and ma'am and
that's my point you ladies all feel like
listen
you ladies all feel like you're the
exception to the rule
and then when someone like myself comes
along and gives you
a a dose of reality instead of just
accepting it it's like yeah but
yeah but i'm special
you don't know any men on this level
that are not your father that aren't
related to you that means you don't know
these men you don't know where to go get
them you don't know what they want
but you're still saying pick me they
don't want mid 30 year old baby mamas
i'm trying to be polite man but they
don't want those
i asked you a question
did you hear what i said
yes
why is that so okay
go ahead
um
my from my point of view i feel like i i
get what you're saying they they do have
better options but also those better
options are younger girls
those younger girls don't necessarily
are necessarily 20 year olds are not
necessarily attracted to 45 year olds
[ __ ] [ __ ]
i'm 51. i can't beat them off with a
stick
that's another one on you lies
no younger women are always younger
women are attracted to older men what
are you talking about
what because they have [ __ ] money
because they can like buy that like they
can literally like we're talking about
seriously they can like skip afting to
work yeah like
like if if a girl was like graduating
college with a [ __ ] psychology degree
and a [ __ ] millionaire walked up to
her and was like like hey like
here's like a life you can go have
instead of like having some shitty job
yeah
well i don't think it's actually money
i'll tell you why okay i think if a guy
won like the lottery i don't think he
would have like as many options as a guy
who's the ceo of a company i think
i think it's more like the power and the
competition
well and the competence yeah women are
attracted to competence
i mean it's swag effective yeah but it's
like self-confidence yeah well even like
like
i used to always say i want to marry
someone in the trades so they could like
do things for me
because i don't want to learn that stuff
like a plumber electricity because i was
like i do not wanna
it's gonna be a no like cars my dad my
brothers do everything for me now so i'm
gonna need to outsource it i like i
really liked what he said though where
it's like you all think you're the
exception to the rule yeah and it's so
true that like people in this situation
like pedalize themselves they're like i
am so special because i've gone through
all of these things and it's like
i could
probably find a million yeah
yeah
so can you see me yes i can
okay
so do you feel like a woman like me
uh-huh what would you rank yourself on a
scale from one to ten you cannot use
seven
would i rate myself just your face
uh my face when i wake up five but when
i put myself together six
okay
and how tall are you
five five dress size
i'm sorry your dress size
okay so that makes you
if you give yourself a five that's
average
yes
so average looking women
tend not to get
high earning men
they tend to get average men
so um did you did you i mean stop right
there stop right there
stop right there breathe and digest
you're 35 years old and you can look
around and see the world
you don't tend to see
higher earning men
with average looking women
off rip
if you do see them she does it the whole
time
but they told me she's probably reading
the comments section uh okay
but well she looked down to the side
that's why i was like oh [ __ ] it's on
her phone
but it's still so disrespectful either
way i also like no offense but like when
you got the big ass fake lashes on dude
like it's not more obvious like oh my
gosh i do as a guy do you like fake
lashes
like i think they're so ugly i also
think that like if a girl has fake
lashes and like claws
oh yeah like you are a high maintenance
like yeah like i've dated that chick
before like her name was crystal which
red flag
if you needed a red flag yeah that's it
but like that's someone who's looking to
be like taken care of like they have a
if they don't have a job that supports
that habit themselves like that that's a
that's a bad investment that's it's just
not what you want i didn't realize we
talked about this yesterday women are so
bad with money like in general well i
also think there's a lot of stuff that
women have to buy that guys don't have
to buy like you know yeah
i mean there's like there's makeup
there's bikini waxes there's like some
stuff and that's like in my opinion
that's why guys should have to pay for
like the first date or
date or two that's a kind of like
the rhythm that it works out to but
maybe i'm
i don't know i'm definitely not super
masculine billy i don't think that i
should have to pay all the time
like i think like you know you should
quickly should be forming into like a
partnership like if you want somebody to
take care of you like i'm not your guy
like but it's like okay yeah it's the
first day or like second date yeah i get
that but then after that like i also
want like
there's something i see with girls a lot
they lack initiative okay like they
get mad like when you don't do
everything where it's like hey are you
free on friday like don't get me wrong
if i'm asking someone out i'm like hey
friday at 7 p.m i don't want to go to
this restaurant like do you want to go
yeah i also want you to be like hey like
i've been wanting to check out this
place i'm driving this right that's not
fun for me yeah well i think that i'm
also paying for it well i think a lot of
times like
girls don't
like realize they have to work to keep a
guy like they don't cook they don't
clean i'm not saying you have to do all
that like maybe like you're good at
something else but like like he's had
girls on the show that said they never
got their boyfriend like a present or
like never got their boyfriend like
christmas presents or like you know just
stop like that like how are you in a
relationship with somebody and you don't
suck
that sloppy topic must be out of this
world
or like those guys just like don't know
better yeah
well the what i was gonna say about the
date though um
i actually used to be really much like
it has to be like the guy pays for
everything yeah and but the reason i did
that was because i felt like if a guy
wasn't doing it that like
he wasn't that interested that's how i
took it but actually like after watching
the manosphere and like realizing all
the [ __ ] guys have to deal with that i
didn't realize before that actually
changed my mind on it because i didn't
realize how many guys just feel like
used by these girls well i mean it's a
numbers game going both ways yeah right
where like if you're on a dating app
you're talking to five people yeah
you're trying you're the type the point
of the app is to get off the app just
get a date right
so i don't think it is for a lot of
people
well maybe i have a little more
intention with my usage or whatever
because like i don't need pen pals yeah
but i get some people want attention
they want valedictorians girls they want
validation they want validation they
drop their instagram and it's they can
like scoop up people to go follow it
sure
but
for me as a guy like i'm trying to get
off that yeah i'm trying to get to the
phone number or to the some other form
of content yeah to go then on the date
to see if there's anything there because
i'm thinking about in terms of like my
investment as time
like
in dating it's
time money to nut ratio basically
where it's like
you know like i'm trying to see if this
is going to work yeah i'm trying to get
there as quickly as possible so i'm a
power dater is like the term i would
best my ex-girlfriend told me i i
i basically give people two-week trials
like
okay where it's like i'm super intense
and super about it and like
the memes are flying i'm texting like
i'm doing like cute stuff like i'm
planning stuff and then like i figure
out whether or not i'm interested okay
like sustain this long term and then
my interest will vanish if i'm not like
i'm not i'm not going to keep it up
right i literally like okay i've gotten
i figured out interesting that's
actually not a bad way to go about it
because i would say two weeks is enough
time to actually like
just not just write them off like right
now you get two to three dates and you
can spend a good amount of time together
like you might after like the first city
like
something i do that i think like a lot
of guys are afraid of is [ __ ] calling
someone on the phone yeah
but i'm like hey like what are you doing
like we're trying to plan yeah something
for next saturday already like i'm just
gonna call you yeah and we're gonna save
you like an hour and a half of time i
think i think that's a good move for
guys yeah i think it shows confidence oh
100 girls girls don't expect it
i used to work in phone sales
and your personality comes out so much
more when you're having a conversation
than like text like i can be flirty on
the phone but if i'm sending like winky
faces and like hissy faces over text
like i might be a weirdo yeah yeah no
that's like that's a good move actually
oh it's i hate i mean i'm not using it
lately for my reasons but like that's
percent the best way where it's like i
might hone in on like one person at a
time
i really can't do more than two people
like i could constantly talk to
i lose my mind wait actually quick
question if you don't hook up with them
in the two weeks do you like i don't
know you don't have to hook up with them
okay there's some guys like if you don't
hook up that's the dating advice right
here in the manosphere it's like if she
doesn't put on a third date get out of
here
um
i think there's
you know there's another side to the
coin on that one where like he i i was
talking to a girl and i talked for like
a month and a half straight up and like
we went on like we were like talking
about like we had all this stuff in
common we like knew each other because
we were like talking so much like we're
like facetiming every night like on a
phone like so it's not like we weren't
spending i'd say like quality time
together we just weren't spending it
necessarily like
face to face because various medical
conditions or travels or like whatever
it was
and um
like i knew she was more conservative
and like more religious and like you
know maybe not being honest with sex
meant more to her than yeah
necessarily to me but
like
i do think that like sexual chemistry is
an essential part of a long-term
romantic relationship even if like the
juan for constant sex like might fade
over time in my experience with the
right person it doesn't
but i got into a huge ass fight with my
friend shane about this because shane is
like a good christian boy yeah he's like
had sex before but he's like i'm not
having sex again until my wedding night
i'm just like that sounds horrible yeah
like i'm like i just fundamentally
disagree with you on that but it doesn't
have to be in that two-week window yeah
i think within like
the three dates you can probably get
into a two-week window without it
feeling like you're like
crash coursing rushing it
you can find out whether or not you have
like chemistry with someone pretty
quickly and like that like you
hopefully have like had the sloppy
yeah even if you just feel the heat a
little bit that's like all you need
really to know right no i was just
curious because they that's like a big
thing in the nanosphere is like a lot of
guys feel like they just waste their
time and money on these girls and then
like they never put out and they're just
like now i'm out all this money well i
think
depending on okay so this is like i i
want to actually make a tech talk about
this for it's like the cost of dating
basically but like
going to get drinks it's like so
ubiquitous it's like the thing you do on
a first date
how expensive do you think four to six
drinks ends up being at like a nice
place that i'm trying to like impress
you by taking you to
it's gonna be like 80 to 100 something
bucks actually it's not a cheap first
date the weird thing is like i kind of
like it when guys don't spend money on
me at first because then i don't feel
like like sure yeah
like i actually
like i've i've told guys like not to
take me places and to take me somewhere
cheaper because i don't i don't want to
feel like because some guys like feel
like you owe them my my ideal first
dates and like this is something i
wanted to talk about was like it's like
coffee or like ice cream i say that's
you're not been stuck there with that
person for over like 45 minutes or like
whatever you're like i can leave like if
you're at a bar
you're waiting on a waiter you're
waiting on another brown you're waiting
on a lot of [ __ ] yeah like that it's
outside of your control
and so you're that's like a two hour to
three hour ordeal like i've had bad
dates at bars that i could not get out
of for like four hours i've never said
yes to dinner on the first date oh [ __ ]
no dinner's a horrible first date was
chipotle i think chipotle is good
because you you can get it
you can get in and out
wait why
i just feel like
at my age like if i went up to like a
girl my age it was like hey chipotle for
they didn't like
they didn't find that insulting wait
really i think so
triple is fire i don't know what they're
talking about okay i'll i'll put it out
there on my instagram after this like
i'm not saying chipotle's not fire i
[ __ ] love people
if you haven't had a conversation with
that person like on the phone yeah
and now you're agreeing to sit across
from them yeah
for two hours no i haven't been on
dating apps in like a long time but last
time i was i would always make guys talk
to me on the phone first yeah so i was
like i'm not trying to get killed out
here well like i yeah when i was like
last time i was on dating apps like i
had just gotten out of a relationship
and i'm like i'm a research nerd
like if it's like yeah like i can
on your profile like you have a unique
name your name is
i will find everything about you that i
can find online
like i don't need to know everything i'm
not but like i do have like an idea of
like where you work how old you are
where you went to school like these are
things that i care about going into like
it not it's the same way that i would
[ __ ] like get ready to interview yeah
because i want to have some ammo in my
pocket about something like i might i
could work into a conversation like i
have like some points or i have like
yeah oh this is probably like
interesting did you know my name's not
pearl
well that makes sense but
it's my middle name actually i just go
by it on the internet my first name is
hannah i think i knew that
they got them they got their average
looking woman when they were both really
young and he built his way up
but a man earning the kind of money
you're talking about does not go for an
average looking woman
i mean my body is not average so but
ma'am you please don't make me say it
hey what
i really just wanted some advice i love
you i'm giving you i'm giving you advice
but you're not taking it the advice is
man
you're average looking at best
i'm taking it in but
okay but you're not accepting the fact
that
okay
average looking women
average looking woman who's
older average looking older woman with a
13 year old son
average looking woman with a 13 year old
son with a sketchy baby daddy
this gets worse every time i say
something and now you're asking for a
man who's in the top 10 of men
you don't qualify for one
and you're making i mean i don't i don't
want to have to go there
but when you put in all these other
factors
why can't you just get a man that's
an average guy
sometimes i feel like um
in order to fully submit i have to feel
like he's in well then you're going to
then you're going to die alone how about
that let me just cut to the chase man
you can feel like what you want to but
women like you die alone
straight up
because you think you're better than the
men that you qualify for and the only
reason honestly ma'am that i can see a
woman like yourself really thinking you
deserve more is because you earn more
because you earn more money than most
people around you in north carolina
but if your ass worked at the post
office you would not think so highly of
your opportunities
and that's the reality we don't
men don't care about your money
not the kind of mean that you want we
don't care about your money
it ain't ours we care about the fact
that you are older and you got kids
and you're average
she just put her phone down
i would be so pissed about it and your
reality of your life has showed you that
you don't have the kind of meaning that
you want knocking on your door trying to
find you
see what we've done in this country this
world is we've told women like yourself
that you can have it all
and you got a prince charming who's six
foot a hundred six feet tall
six figure income jawline all this other
kind of stuff and i'm sorry man
no
most people get average people
especially average people
your average person
i mean let's be real you're not running
microsoft you got you had a pet grooming
business
you've been making six figures for the
last three years
okay
but if i'm looking at you but if i
looked at you and i took all that off
for you
all the eyelashes and all the hair what
do you look like under there
i mean i look the same i'm just no you
don't because if you did you wouldn't
have all that on
i'm sorry
no you don't you don't look the same
because if you did you wouldn't have all
that on
so
what is your advice
for uh
all right i'll tell you my advice man
because you're not listening to me
that's why i always recommend you just
you need therapy
everyone people think most of us in
black community need therapy but you're
not you're not dealing with reality
i asked you about your child's father
and you couldn't answer me
but it doesn't sound like you're too
proud of him
how's it what's kind of student is your
child
he's a a student
does he have any behavioral problems
no he actually got a youtube channel and
he's trying to don't need that i don't
need no no no
but where is it but his daddy is still
[ __ ] daddy
does he have a relationship with his
father
then what's your issue with him
um he's not um business-minded like my
father and my uncle and then why'd you
choose to make a baby with him before
you got married
younger
exactly and that cost
see that young and dumb [ __ ] city 13
yeah i know the numbers don't happen let
me stop you right here that young and
dumb [ __ ] you black women throw out as
if it's supposed to get
listen and you do that man yeah well
i was
like so we were just [ __ ] around with
him for like eight years and then
he dipped like
but i actually love his point where it's
like what's your problem with him then
like if he's got he's got a relationship
with your son your son's got no behavior
problems like he has good grades like
and she goes he's not like my dad or my
uncle
well that's the that's the thing a lot
of girls will leave like thinking
they'll get better do you remember when
you said the girls always come back
yeah because they leave because they can
do better straight up it's happening so
many times but like they're older
and more more youth i actually have a
really good story about this
like you can maybe do a better up to
like i don't know 25 i actually have a
perfectly okay what's the story so when
i was in college when i was a senior
there was this girl that went to a
school over from me okay so for anyone
watching i went to emory in atlanta this
girl went to kennesaw state it's like
not a good school really but she was a
model straight up she was a model had a
contract so like
you know like
yeah she was hot and so like i went out
through a bunch of different times like
brought her to events at my school stuff
like that like and she called my ass out
for like not committing basically
she was like you don't really seem like
you're like about it about it and i was
like damn i just got called out so i
like i was like okay i'm [ __ ] about
it so like i remember i showed up to her
house i brought like flowers like took
her to like a nice test dinner and i was
going on spring break with my friends
and
i was like yo like i'm going for like a
week but like i'm serious about this and
like this is like what i want to do
and she's like okay cool and then i'm on
the boat straight up and i start seeing
pictures getting posted from like a
modeling shoot but it's hurting this
dude and it's looking intimate and so
like i text her i'm like hey like it
looks a little weird like yeah what's up
she's like no it's nothing two days
later in a relationship so i was getting
played the entire time right i literally
got played okay so anyway fast i was
just i was very
gracious about it as i was like okay
like you know you do you whatever
fast forward to
not even a year later
and she's texting me like apologizing to
me like telling me how much of how big
of a mistake she's made like yeah she
still texts me to this day really she's
still she joins my tic toc live
sometimes she like really drools on my
instagram photos she saw that salary one
she's like i fumbled the bag her mom
tells her she crumbled the bag
and like i'm sorry she is not as
good-looking as she used to be like i am
now far out of her league so what is she
is she what would you say she was then
and what is she now uh i would i'd
probably give her a nine then she was
she was really good-looking and then
what is she now
is she fat now is that why she got
bulkier
and like for her that the weight does
not it's like it sits on her chin badly
yeah like she maybe had some work it
always looks really bad if girls get
botox and then gain weight i didn't know
that but i
yeah it's i could show you pictures yeah
let me see
i'm gonna we're gonna show it to me
after the video we got two minutes
listen well women young and dumb is not
a get out of jail free card it doesn't
go woof and change the fact
you still have to carry that consequence
and men are not rushing up to be
stepfathers to 13 year olds
what would be better is if you honestly
sat down and asked yourself
what value can i bring to a man
and i know that what i can well
all right what can what value what what
is it
what is it
i can help him with this business i'm
very business minor on the um end of
health and organizer and
i plant um into planting my own garden
so
i can definitely plant i'm into um
improving my etigans with um
just self-improvement and
working on myself and
that's like a whole lot of nothing 35
years old at 35 years old here's what
you're telling me
i can help him with his business due
respect ma'am
um and i mean no disrespect but 20 to 30
percent of people own businesses what
about the 70 to 80 of men who don't own
them
that means that doesn't matter
that means nothing to the average man
then the next thing you said
i can plant
man
that means nothing to most people
because we go to grocery stores
then you say
self-improvement you've had
i gave you a shot at saying what you
have to offer to men and you said
nothing that we value
what do you think what do you got book a
session
he's been telling you the whole time he
literally
doesn't want it
i've tried to go around but this happens
the older you ladies get the more you
get set in your waves book a session
because i don't want to do this in
public man because you seem like a sweet
woman but you don't but you're not
getting it you're being so mean i'm not
being don't tell me i'm being mean
i'm about to be mean i get tired of you
broads telling me i'm being mean because
you cannot handle the damn truth you
called my show on the day the training
was supposed to be here and i honored
the call and sat here and tried to help
you and i'm telling you telling me i'm
being mean the [ __ ] out of my phone
tired of y'all doing this [ __ ]
yeah that was amazing
what what are your um
what are your final thoughts it's just
like it's just
you know people don't want to hear the
truth right like they want to hear what
they want to hear
they don't
that's why i stop giving advice to
people after like i give them advice and
they don't listen
like you give them advice you know what
they need to do
they probably know then they don't do it
and then they come back to you with the
same problem and you're like we're not
doing this again right like she didn't
want to be helped she didn't she wanted
him to solve her problems well she
wanted to be heard i think she just
wanted to talk
and like like tell him about her problem
what's like the magic solution that he's
going to give her like hey here's the
secret dating app for like average
chicks that have been run through fine
dudes with six major jobs like congrats
like you came to me on my on my off day
so now i'm going to give you magical
access to like like my contact book like
what
yeah i think you're right i think she's
just one event yeah yeah like she's just
like
i'm better than these people but like
you're not well as a girl i've actually
thought about this like i think
sometimes when we get emotional like
we're not really looking for a solution
and that's like something i've kind of
trained myself because my dad's taught
me that as a guy as a guy i know better
than to like give a girl a solution like
she's like if you just want to then like
you know like you're having a bad day
like i'm not going to offer you like hey
here's how to fix it it's like you just
want you just want to be heard yeah so
i'm just going to take it in yeah
go yeah well that's something my dad
like i i like trained myself to do i'll
be like if i'm mad about something like
okay what would the solution be to this
instead of just complaining about it
it's hard though like i think it goes
against like women's nature
like i think we're naturally just more
emotional
i think like obviously venting is always
it's a good way to get out that
frustration but like that woman in that
video that's a very like deep-seated
yeah like that's like probably 10 years
of frustration in there maybe three
years you know since she started making
six figures right
i just don't believe she makes six
figures
like i would want to like i want like a
tour of like her house in the facility
because i don't think that some lady
who's a dog groomer pet
yeah
where's her desk where is her dad right
you have if you have if you're making
six figures like you're a business you
can afford a desk you have an office
or something like she's sitting in a
room with her i had the same sheets in
my apartment in san francisco straight
up like i recognized that bed spread you
buy it on amazon yeah like
i know that so like
also i think one other thing to her to
her thing
that's not a skill job right that's not
something like you're a hairdresser
you're a hairdresser that makes six
figures because you have a couple of
like high-end clients like you're still
a hairdresser right like it's not like
yeah i'm the vp or like i'm the director
at a company that's like reputable it's
like
okay like i don't understand
this thing like
that's what i don't know it's a little
weird and then also like mode if the
guys don't like dogs or like
there's so many things that she just
opened up of like problems like i can't
imagine like well it makes it more she
has the kid right and so like does the
kid help with the business after school
like yeah i just
the kid is an absolute like it's an
absolute deal breaker like you could be
35 an average and maybe like
you know find a nice guy who's also
average looking but right i don't think
she was going for tens i don't think
that's what she was just trying to find
dude who had some money right like so
maybe she would and she's five five so
it's not like
five seven dudes or like five six
students like would necessarily be
a no-go but the kid just like the kid
there's baby there's baby daddy drama
like apparently like
tell me tell me about this um because my
i always use my sister as an example on
the channel she was married to a guy
they had two kids together they got
divorced she got remarried like very
quickly to a new guy um and he makes i'm
pretty sure six figures and he's like
good like i would say he checks like a
lot of women's boxes but and i asked
them like what's the difference between
my sister and a lot of girls and a lot
of people on the channel said like men
look at it differently if it's a baby
daddy versus an ex-husband yes would you
say okay yeah
yeah 100 yeah i would agree because
they're like why he didn't put a ring on
it why should i
well yeah it devalues
the good if you will right yeah like you
know if you made an honest
you made an honest run at it yeah you
did things the right way and it didn't
work out like you can look at that as
like an adult and be like yeah that's
like normal but like yeah you got
[ __ ] knocked up at a frat party and
like
like whatever it is yeah like you know
it's your high school like in the back
of the car like you're irresponsible
right between like responsibility and
your responsibility right by definition
right
it's interesting because a lot of his
points are like because you're gonna
make six figures so like it kind of
lines up like all the things you're
saying with like what kevin samuel says
yeah so it kind of gives him like an
extra layer of like credibility that
you're like vouching for most of the
stuff i mean like i don't like i think
sometimes he gets a little high on his
horse yeah like
but i don't disagree with someone with
his points yeah like i think
but also like based on what i've seen
like a lot of the callers coming in like
well they're not they're not yeah
they're they're situations yeah
and i don't i don't wanna say it's like
a little predatory maybe but he's like
getting like easy cannon fodder they
call in though they do call it and and
the second thing is like obviously the
worst ones are going to get the most
views you know what i mean like there's
normal girls that call in it's just like
i i've called into a show before
actually really did you talk to him uh
yeah i did
i mean it didn't really he just uh what
did he say he just asked me
if i had a boyfriend oh no because the
whole thing was um
it was talking about do you need men and
i just called in and was like yeah i
can't do anything
like
i literally can't do anything like i
just felt like with like guys stuff
right like i i
i need my dad and if i don't go to my
dad i go to my brother and if i don't go
to that brother and then my other
brother
and if i don't do that then i'll go hire
a man to do it like
good [ __ ] yeah
but okay guys
sorry this was a long video today but i
think it was good awesome
do not forget to subscribe to the
channel tell them where they can find
you send into mike you can find me on
tick tock ken and you can find me on
instagram at wax on wax off that's
w-a-k-s on w-a-k-s off sweet that's what
i do
don't forget to subscribe to the channel
bring that notification bell i'll talk
to you guys next time